Mình hịt mắt với định số sinh đường là mấy đăng cưới của cập đối ở VN.
Theo lựa dùng của tâm miền, nhà bà sân tổ chức đăng cưới cho con, chủ sẻ năng này bà mì tụi
với cưới được phở, nền mực hịt mắt, sẽ đing tổ chức đăng cưới ninh mong mọi người
không đi đường này, kém bi ngại vui tệnh chỉ đốt để đi không bị vướng giặt với.
Được biết, khi ngàn chưa được chức tà con đường, nếu chức nhà bà phân tị sôi, sống xen hạ, sạ tình lĩnh
bệnh tình chương nghệ ăn, tây mừng bởi tháng mời, tài đing bà sân dựng giặt để tổ chức đăng cưới cho mời con trái nế bà phục,
lệ cưới chính thức sĩnh xả vòng hay mực tạm tháng mời.
Anh phục tắc giả của tấm biệt sinh đường gọi trên trong nghiệp, ở vui, đăng mi tối chờ lấy được vợ thực xanh là a giồi.
Bối lần tổ đi làm về, các cơ bác chúng sống lại chêu, hỏi đôi dựa cưới vợ,
không này tự gửi vợ dụi dụi dụi, nền chân tụi khai khai hồi mọi người.
Sà định tối xử dụi dụi, tình có chắn mất một phần đường sẽ gửi đến việc ý lạc của bác con nguyên xanh trúng sống.
Tối dụi tấm biệt, mừng bà con bò qua trở sự bất biệt trong bà sĩnh xí truyền có đầy, anh phút nói.